Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P here is a 17 year old
kid who called in who says, I've grown up being
afraid of being shot in school because of these
mass shootings. Let's listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hi, David. It's August
from Wisconsin. And I'm just here to talk
about the shooting. I was 17 years old
and I had to grow up every day thinking
about what someone with a gun would do to me.
And I'm incredibly outraged at what all of you
adults haven't done. Right. And I think you're
all a coward for not having solved this problem
earlier and should all be able to vote. And you
have been for many years. And so let's do that.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Hard. Hard to even really follow
that up. So I won't try to. We are going
to talk about a bunch of different things
on the bonus show. We are going to talk about a
new policy on excessive force for police officers.
We're going to talk about a whole bunch of other
things. If you're interested, sign up at join
pacman dot com and otherwise we'll be back with a.
Unidentified: New show on.